اعلنتها نيجيريا على التنظيمات الارهابيه
كانت اخر نتائجها قتل اعداد من عناصر بوكو
حرام وعمليه ادت الى مقتل قائد تنظيم داعش
في المنطقه
نشاط متصاعد للسلطات الافريقيه ناجم عن
اتساع رقعه نفوذ تلك التنظيمات المتطرفه
في القاره السمراء خصوصا تنظيم داعش فقد
افادت احصائيات اجرتها المراكز الدوليه
المتخصصه منها معهد واشنطن للدراسات
والمركز الوطني لمكافحه الارهاب بان داعش
يتقدم بنفوذه على حساب القاعده لينتشر
بشكل كبير في منطقه الساحل الافريقي خصوصا
مالي وتشاد ويتحرك النحو نيجيريا بحسب
تقديرات مؤشر الارهاب العالمي كما استطاع
انتزاع ولاء بعض الجماعات المتطرفه
المرتبطه بالقاعده في المنطقه
وتيره الهجمات الارهابيه تصاعدت على مدى
الاشهر الماضيه من اعتداءات وتفجيرات
وعمليات ليس فقط بين المدنيين بل بين داعش
والقاعده وكل من يتماشى مع فكرهما خصوصا
مع اندثار التنظيمين من منطقه الشرق
الاوسط
الفوضى وعجز في السلطه وهشاشه في الاوضاع
السياسيه والامنيه كلها عوامل ادت الى
توسع نفوذ الجماعات المتطرفه في القاره
السمراء ورغم التراجع النسبي في ضحايا
الارهاب الا ان التحذيرات الامنيه تشير
الى عدم الاستهانه بداعش تحديدا خاصه بعد
سحب فرنسا قواتها العسكريه من القاره
لصالح روسيا اذا عمر العربيه